a tragedy instructors hector discovers
his friend has overdosed how can she be
saved
well first Hector must know what opiates
are stay silent falls to the ground and
hurts her knee in this case the body
will release where I called endogenous
opioids to help her out against the pain
these include endorphins and cough Allen
sendin orphan however an opioid is
anything that binds to an opiate
receptor therefore there opioids which
come from outside our body but interact
with the opioid receptors in the same
way these are called exhaust opioids
there are three opioid receptors to
which they bind new thang up receptors
and they are all part of a group of
receptors called g-protein coupled
receptors or GPCR let's view a model of
this this part is the receptor itself
from the seven heel seats which go
through the membrane on the outside of
the cell there's a cavity to which an
agonist like an opioid binds on the
intracellular side the receptor is
coupled to a g-protein which has an
alpha beta and gamma subunit when an
agonist binds the g-protein activates
the GDP molecule bound to the alpha
subunit is released and replaced with
GTP the protein dissociates into the
alpha subunit and the beta gamma subunit
both of which can now interact with
other protein pathways for example alpha
interact with adenylyl cyclase and the
alpha protein can stimulate or inhibit
based on the type this enzyme uses ATP
to produce cmp CA MP is a secondary
messenger which is involved in many
different responses an opioid can use
this mechanism to inhibit this enzyme
and then prevent pain signals eventually
the body becomes dependent on and
tolerant of the drugs leading the body
to want more addictions often begin with
prescription drugs and then go out of
control this has led to an opioid crisis
to prevent misuse people must only take
the prescribed amount of drugs not share
medications and stay educated on the
opioid crisis it is important to solve
this crisis because as many 128 people
die each day from overdose in the US the
hoc and Hector's friend be saved from an
overdose an opioid is an agonist but
they're also antagonists such as an alec
zone which combines an opiate receptor
in the same way but not affect the
g-protein why is this important well now
that it is bound to the receptor the
opiate can no longer bind preventing its
effects knowing this it is possible for
Hector to save his friends life he just
needs to be prepared and stay informed
[Music]